[Music]
we live in a country that has incredible
abundance
but if you were to add up all of the
hungry people
in los angeles county and its contiguous
counties as well you'd have a state of
hunger the size of new mexico or west
virginia two and a half million people
to me it is a mandate for us to do
better around this and it's so simple
it's just sharing abundance
my name is rick nemias i'm founder and
executive director of food forward
our mission is to recover fresh produce
that would otherwise go to waste and get
it to people in need we started in 2009
and it really was just walking around my
neighborhood and seeing all these fruit
trees dripping with citrus that i
realized that with a few volunteers
there might be a project here that i
could help facilitate eight and a half
years later and 43 million pounds later
here we are
[Music]
we have fed over one and a half million
people this year we have three programs
backyard harvest literally going into
folks homes who have agreed to have us
in there taking excess produce from
their trees sometimes their gardens
the second program that was added a
couple years later was farmer's market
recovery we're at about 24 farmers
markets every single week with volunteer
teams
and then the big one is the wholesale
recovery which works kind of under cloak
of darkness
we get up super early
usually before the sun even comes up
and are out there with our trucks
gathering pallets and entire truckloads
of food that is perfectly viable but for
whatever reason would otherwise end up
in a trash dump
we're looking at things that just might
have a slight discoloration or a slight
bruise on them
it still has weeks left to its life but
it's not perfect and that's where we get
called
[Music]
we have learned that that hunger hides
in plain sight here in society
there should be no shame around it
unfortunately there is but the more that
we bring abundance out and really give
people food with dignity and give them
quality healthy nutritious food
these issues will slowly go away
[Music]
indian weddings are really huge
on an average indian wedding there is
always 100 to 150 plates of excess food
that's where we are coming in collecting
it and distributing it to the needy
[Music]
indians produce 10.8 percent of the
world's food but we have more and more
people hungry in india sleeping without
food
i am padmanaban gopalan
i started non-profit no food waste in
2014.
no food waste is an excess food recovery
network that collects untouched surplus
food from various events and parties and
delivers to the hunger spots across the
city like orphanages slums old age homes
dump yards and government hospitals
as of today we have collected and
distributed about 285 000 plates of food
to the needy people
we launched a helpline number that is
displayed in across the marriage halls
and the hotels when there is excess food
people call to the shelf line number
then we organized pickups with our
vehicles and
this food is being served within four
hours of collection
[Music]
no food waste initially started in koi
matura and now we are in almost 10
cities it is only because of volunteers
the number of calls is very huge
right now we are able to cover only 30
to 35 percent of the calls what we
receive
to arrange logistics and infrastructure
to recover food from all these marriage
falls becomes a challenge
people are generally aware of food waste
problem in their marriages and events
but they were not aware of what to do
with this excess food
there is no words to explain the pain of
hunger the success of no food waste is
to see a food waste free india and a
hunger free india
when we collected all this food and
delivered to the slums in different
areas people feel happy about it and
seeing smiles on those people makes us
really happy to continue this job
feed people not landfills
[Music]
produce industry does not have the right
to dump nutritious product that can go
to families who are in need
[Music]
borderlands food bank rescues between 30
to 40 million pounds of produce annually
and we've been doing it for 21 years
[Music]
my name is rolanda soto and i am the ceo
president of borderlands food bank
[Music]
we are an organization that rescues
fresh produce we get it to families all
over the state of arizona and 19 other
states within the nation
we saw there was a tremendous amount of
fresh produce coming across at our port
of entry here from mexico and a lot of
it could not be sold
it could be because it had some scarring
it could be because it had some rain
stain
and so they were actually dumping it in
the landfill
we saw that the product was extremely
good
for human consumption so we began
educating the produce industry
we've gone to each individual
distributor we've offered them our
services and said do not dump
allow us to rescue it and get it to
families so that they can eat
nutritiously
the driver comes back to the warehouse
he's got a trailer load of product and
he begins to get unloaded
we take up the produce to the sites and
we set it up like a farmer's market all
done by volunteers from the host site
for a ten dollar
the supporter can select 60 pounds of
produce pretty good 17 cents a pound
[Music]
it's important to us to get it to as
many families as possible before it
perishes because i think that people
have the right to eat nutritiously it's
the most basic of needs thank you have a
great day
we have
the responsibility
to stop waste and we have the
responsibility to help the people in our
own backyard
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is what it sounds like when 3 500
people are eating together
and another 3 500
and another
in total today the shirdi sai baba
temple in maharashtra india will serve
lunch to at least 40 000 people for free
and this happens every day
365 days a year
the temple was built in 2008 around a
specific philosophy by spiritual leader
[Music]
of
[Music]
he supervises the kitchen or mega
kitchen as this is one of the largest in
asia
the day it starts at 6 30 in the morning
foreign
some people are cooking vegetables some
clean utensils some are responsible for
the bread
you get it
[Applause]
every day the meal is different but the
ratio is always the same
subject
chapter
[Music]
to make these plates for 40 000 people a
day it takes a lot of food here are the
numbers
3.3 tons of bread
two tons of vegetables
nearly one ton of lentils and half a ton
of dessert
now to make all this food the kitchen
requires a lot of power
the roof is covered in solar panels
so it's clear this temple's initiatives
are something to be proud of
[Music]
the village of kamikatsu is special
not for its tea fields or idyllic
mountains or peaceful historic homes
it's known for something it doesn't have
kamikatsu as a town produces almost no
trash
[Music]
kamikatsu has a population of roughly 1
500 people and in the 1990s was doing
nearly no recycling
burning all that garbage created carbon
dioxide emissions that became dangerous
and the nature around them was suffering
so a decision was made
kamikatsu had to change
this was the start of their path towards
zero waste and a new way of living
effectively what zero waste here means
is that there's no such thing as
throwing something in the trash
everything has to get recycled
and in the beginning it was difficult
for everyone
like mr takuya takaichi he's a shop
owner in kamekazu
[Music]
classical
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that classification system she's talking
about is the key to kamikaze's success
and it is aggressive
there are 45 categories of recyclables
[Music]
[Music]
a list it goes on there's 35 more
slowly what was originally this huge
burden became a way of life in kamikatsu
people began looking at trash
differently
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's important to recognize that
kamikatsu is a small town it is not like
new york or london the rules are not the
same but there is a constant and that's
people they can change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you